I don't want to tell you a story.
I want to make a case.
I want to make a hardheaded, evidence - based, dare I say lawyerly case...
...for rethinking how we run our businesses.
So ladies and gentlemen of the jury, take a look at this.
This is called the candle problem.
Some of you might have seen this before.
It's created in 1945 by a psychologist named Karl Duncker.
Karl Duncker created this experiment that he used in a whole variety of experiments in behavioral science.
And here's how it works.
Suppose I'm the experimenter.
I bring you into a room.
I give you a candle, some thumbtacks and some matches.
And I say to you,...
"Your job is to attach the candle to the wall so the wax doesn't drip onto the table."
Now, what would you do?
Many people begin trying to thumbtack the candle to the wall.
Doesn't work.
Somebody, some people; and I saw somebody kind of make the motion over here.
Some people have a great idea where they light the match,...
...melt the side of the candle, try to adhere it to the wall.
It's an awesome idea.
Doesn't work.
And eventually after five or ten minutes, most people figure out the solution,...
...which you can see here.
The key is to overcome what's called functional fixedness.
You look at that box and you see it only as a receptacle for the tacks...
...but it can also have this other function, as a platform for the candle.
The candle problem.